ich bin auf dem weg mein lieber ja und
das heißt nicht chaos sondern krank ist
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer endlich mal wieder
neuen folge hetero zusammen mit unseren
könig pages to high je einem
wunderschönen guten tag auch von meiner
seite aus und hört ist willkommen zurück
hier ich stehe ich stehe auf irgendein
tower durch den westen auf dem server
sind zwei leute noch drauf nun mein
lieber scholli dna und hatte mein gott
ich muss hier erstmal scripts blitzgerät
teddy boy und anderen das kopf geht mal
bitten wird ja bei gott nein schön
schlafen link nein eher leute erst mal
eine ganz kurze erklärung ist als
tschuldigung das jemals ins bett ich
kann nicht ins bett ich bin bin irgendwo
im tower alter jedoch hat kein bett ja
erstmal an euch leute an euch leute da
es kam so lange keine folge weil kilos
ich erklärt jetzt mal ganz kurz eben
gerade
ich hätte das ding macht das mal nicht
gebaut dass man das jetzt hier und zwar
kamen so lange keine folgen weil ich hab
mir neuen pc gekauft schreibt eure
kommentare ob ich den ball irgendwie
vorstellen soll oder irgendwie durch die
werte sagen soll keine ahnung
jedenfalls komet der schon verstärkt ich
habe das nicht wo ich glaube hier bei
mir schön schön schön schon schön vor
ihrem eintritt team erdinger jo was habe
ich ich weiss es nicht ist auch gut so
ein diamant hast du hast du fertig
erklärt ich hab dich ganz zugehörig
erledigt deswegen zwischen und zwar habe
ich ein systemabbild erstellt mit allen
meinen dateien mit einem programm mit
photoshop adobe bla bla bla bla mit
allen youtube dateien außerdem mit
meinem intro mit jako o polo jetta mit
allen dateien die ich irgendwie so hatte
so systemabbild schillig ich habe meine
neuen pc will das system peter
draufladen beim wc sagt mir systemabbild
ist beschädigt bitte starten sie den pc
neu starten pc neue systemabbild ist
beschädigt bitte starten sie den pc neu
startet system neu bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla die ganze zeit einfach mein
leben lang einfach die ganze zeit so was
gab's locker fünf sechs mal probiert es
ist einfach beschädigt im twin zum
kumpel gegangen bei ihm winken höhe
dann ging es einfach auch nicht mein
holz verändert altenholz verändert sich
gerade das ist coupé feiert sich legal
ist kacke egal
ein bisschen einer schönen moment
vielleicht kann ich nichts dafür nicht
ausdrücken
hier klappt nicht gut hätten wir
vielleicht kann ich jetzt lachen darüber
nicht glücklich
a ja schade dass mit red bull hier halte
ich erzähle weiter ich lasse mich nicht
von solchen intelligenz besten video zu
dem song bzw unseren könig diese bist du
endlich im tower drin der der schlägt
blutet wurde alter er wurde nicht
gelötet richtig nett auch noch monster
drin und spanner und deine mama aber gut
monster der der da war frech wer das
brutale also ja nicht weil das das spiel
bestimmt jedenfalls ging das hat alles
nicht und ich dann erstmal hier komplett
alles normal läuft habe ich hier gar
keine dateien darauf aus exit und
spotify das wichtigste was ihr braucht
photoshop dauer blabla ganze paket rap
szene mit ihm bis dann auch den euro
sondern auch und vor allem ja alles weg
mal vor allem diese drei gigabyte
pornoseite war und ich hoffe dass mit
jorge ich habe sogar schon eine folge
aufgenommen allerdings ist dann halt
wieder alles abgestütztes komplette
system das seht ihr daran dass ich hier
schon tunnel gebaut hat mir habe ich
aber nicht gebaut
ich mache hier mit vw noch ein bisschen
mehr habe ich aber noch nicht gebaut war
nur ein bisschen da ganz hin in dem wald
drin und habe mir ein bisschen holz
geholt habe das dann halt hier jetzt mal
so alles daran gebaut und so sieht das
jetzt bei mir aus aber nicht viel neues
gemacht nur ich fand halt ein bisschen
doof jetzt mal sorry das geht jetzt
nicht an die leute die hier aktive
kommentarschreiber und zuschauer bei mir
sind und nicht mögen aber paar leute bei
facebook habe ich anscheinend nur wegen
hero abonniert und haben gesagt na die
hochgehandelte abonniere ich das
natürlich nicht schön
also ich meine ich setze mein ganzes
leben daran hier irgendwie was zu reißen
zum beispiel heute ich komme aus der
schule und findet nach vier fahrstunde
doppel ständig danach klinik ich
weihnachten zu hause glaubt denn was
gegessen und dann fordern leute dass ich
noch irgendein pc dann hinkriegen dass
der neue vom kuchen das machen jedoch
sag doch mal ja ja okay das ist auch
total auf meiner seite das ist wirklich
nicht schlecht
ja ich und ich jetzt nicht alles vorher
so ein bisschen dass man da dann auch er
nennt ist auch wirklich hat mir wirklich
jeden tag geschrieben und hat gesagt
leute das hat mich total fertig mein mal
alles so passiert ja das habe ich immer
gut im alter was ist denn da passiert
und all das ist aber dass die
entschuldigung also jedes grad in
wallendorf sagen ja jedoch separat in
seiner hose alt kommt gleich einen cross
japans das gewachsene alter des größter
gewinner ist verloren habe was ich sagen
wollte er das natürlich verständlich
dass da so was irgendwie ahnt ist in den
punkten wenn es nicht anders geht geht's
ja nicht anders aber ist jetzt wieder da
unser lieber conny und wir haben auch
tierisch vermisst in unserer stadt so
das gefühl oh ja und es wurden über alt
wurden auch schon ging's festgelegt hab
ich gehört
ja ja ja sie das gleiche lied mein
lieber er hat mir redet schon halbwegs
gezeigt kannst mir dass eventuell gleich
mal ganz kurz er vorstellt was du denn
bisher hier so schon getan hast ja ich
muss auch mal alles irgendwann viele
leute haben gesagt ich soll doch mal
bitte so eine art sich sammelt hat ganz
viel mit tüten gestanden ich ganz geil
ich sag mal so eine art regel bleibt
vielleicht in die stadt machen das werde
ich auch tun
er förderte auch schon gemacht gerade
habe ich allerdings keinen plan hat das
man von mir dass ich meine gedanken über
soja
im jahr genau und das werden wir noch
machen also grundsätzlich so schnelle
zusammenfassung ist schwierig die
ämterverteilung habe ich also apple mit
cap macht so ein auf waffenmeister das
heißt er so für das thema zuständig also
der guckt einfach dazu dass waffen an
land kommen für alle wir wollen
versuchen ein bisschen gemeinschaftlich
etwas zu machen ja morgens am 8
minenarbeiter das heißt die kümmern sich
um ärzte und so ein gedöns der song back
kümmert sich um die schoko bofa muntere
wieder baut eine stadtmauer der ist
immer noch baumeister wie in der
königsball wurde leider auch nicht ob
bei was man erreicht wurde so und regeln
sind folgende erstens untereinander wird
sich nicht getötet
zweitens untereinander wird nicht
geklaut und drittens falls irgendwie so
ein fall vorkommen sollte kann man
öffentliches gericht einfordern von mir
das heißt da gibt's gerichts folge dann
da muss ich noch mal machen und zwar wo
ich dass er mit der brocken sams machen
weil ihr mirjam ein schoko mitgenommen
haben allerdings haben sich malte manuel
das nur ausgeliehen und haben das jetzt
auch wieder zurückgebracht ich will
jetzt allerdings nicht mehr das hier
obwohl ich schon geil aber ich glaube
ich möchte lieber eins von den hier
vorne und zwar zeige ich euch mal ganz
kurz den popo stall die mich auch schon
haben und 20 bisschen verändert die wege
sind nur noch scheiße wäre es für wege
zuständig für terraforming gute idee
wenn du lust hast kannst du auch ein
bisschen wege und dass unser tun wir
haben blaue und grüne chocobo
vergesslich essen zu besorgen man ja ja
klarheit indem genug gehört und man ihm
selten so felder in stuff ich nehme mir
so einfach geht denke ich ja die meisten
ja das ist in ordnung wenn ein wirt jahr
abgezogen was bringt da nichts mit
theorien gestein genau kann das mal
jemand in die kommentare schreiben
vielleicht wenn dann ab wenn das frisch
ist nicht gut
ja es ist ein balanceakt zwischen grünen
und blauen noch mal blaue kann doch
durch wasser und grünen kann berge hoch
null plan
da muss man den drucker beauftragten
fragen rufen doch mal auf seiner
privaten handynummer an
gut 40 beziehung nicht mitnehmen da sind
denen es unterschiedliche drin bombays
yoko ja du nämlich jetzt ein kleiner den
grünen auf das was du bist du da bist du
liebe grünen herz schnauze gefallen
erzählt auch mal nein wir machen hier
keine keine privaten wahl denn windows
auf die wahl beziehst auf parteien
das ist das was das label studie schon
wieder ich verstehe dich nicht behindert
bist ok blau blau ist bloß schnell im
wasser und grün ist grüner chocobo ist
doch berge
zwei andere sparkurs hat er die ahnung
und blau wasser läuft zwei blöcke hoch
chillig ok danke viki ficki wie viel
ressourcen ich einfach immer auf meinen
trips einsammeln also das ist also nicht
auf meinen drogentrips natürlich sehr
schnell aber ich meine auf meinen kassen
trips durch die welt ich komme jetzt mal
zu dir ja da bin ich diesmal ins gesicht
treten kann ich kann ja aber kein
mitnehmen von denen man nicht die kann
ich dir den ruinen töten
töte alle die grünen co
ich hoffe dass er mich mag ja wie kann
ich das machen andere frisur oder sowas
also bei dir jetzt mein job meine liebe
ananas dass es überall meteorit bei uns
nicht so intuitiv verwöhnen mit der
zunge mit der zunge ok du bei mir
nachtessen chat folge dass ich gerade
nicht eigentlich auch mitglieder
glock der es um geil gerade hier ist
aber einer mit bunten kehrt keine bunten
federn bunte wäre das eigentlich
weiblich egal ich bleibe erstmal bei
dings um bei dingsbums ticker bei jacky
komplett zurück ich bin auf dem weg mein
lieber ja und das heißt nicht guido
sondern krank ist schon wieder was fürs
für who are albums dich ins knie
was ist da so ein scheiß das jedoch so
gewaltige erkennst du diese schülerinnen
oder wir heißen die visual diesem job
ich scheiße ich glaube mich aber von
schaaf und ich habe diesen doofen pickel
auf meiner nase in den sieht man von
interface kann ja ich bin voll und
schafft man was da ist das ist aber das
liegt an der kamera
vielleicht hast du glück und vielleicht
hast du glück und es läuft vielleicht
und wie clearasil werbung von deinem
video oder sowas dann passt das auch
noch heiße kannst du nicht eine folge
von hannah montana wo sie ein pickel hat
und dann lässt du denn erst retuschieren
auf plakat und dann macht sie ihn wieder
dran und dann ist das voll die message
an alle jungen girlies out that you
never mastiaux pickles because you're
beautiful in matches
danke dass man neben bereich hat
bitteschön ich möchte nur die jugend von
heute dazu motivieren ihr gesicht auf
plakate pinseln zu lassen mit pickel und
akne damals du in deiner jugend also vor
zwei monaten live richtig nicht so
richtig gut ich hab doch nie was gegen
gemacht irgendwie gegen gegen pickel
ich habe wo ich will meinen garten
steigen und ich stehe einfach in eine
höhle herab aber dies ausgleich ist das
hier alles ich gucke mich mal ein
bisschen oben
das sieht so aus visionen wie so ein
arschloch auskosten
ach so ja gut wie so ein entwendeter
darum du okay schockiert doch jetzt
eigentlich dings
junge tot ist aber auch ein scheint ihr
alter aber egal leute wie haben jockey
zurück und ich würde sagen wir machen
jetzt ein schöner ausflug mit jockey
machst machst du mir übrigens schon mal
was zu essen klar ich bin gleich da
würde die frau ihr werdet das ist das
wirklich zu allen war ich bis der tiere
schnitt ja aber zu dir irgendwie ist das
das gmail das war der weide beiden bei
der ersten folge dass micha behandelt
wie dreck du kannst mir heuer endgültig
habe die getötete texas ziemlich
behandelt deine zukünftigen könig hast
du von anfang an in den schmutz getreten
mit dreckigen stiefel an denen noch die
kaugummi reste aus der letzten nacht im
hamburger hof klebten ich erst mal
meinen job machen dann kommst du ein
bisschen durch den tunnel fahren gesehen
und das gleich jung grund mein sattel
leben die einfach mit
januar junge broken flowers sollen das
ist nicht mein schoko weg oder was zu
sagen
dann behalten den sattel hast du den
sattel für mich ich habe gar nichts mit
dem tod
hier war ein ton ja was wollte ich
wollte ich wurde ja irgendwas müssen wir
so genau was mein lieber mein lieber
lieber conny die mach ich wie mache ich
ein rezept in meinen inventar so rein
du meinst so recht aus dem aus dem ding
ja dass du siehst wie das gecastet wird
ja ich glaube das wurde mir irgendwie
erklärt dass das mit moment du drückst
glaube ich drauf und dann auch oder nein
geht es bei mir geht aus
also effekt muss ich sagen geht nicht
also ich bekomme da irgendwelches zeug
ich möchte auch noch ich möchte ja auch
noch seine rüstung kräften aus mir wurde
jetzt übrigens ich hab das in den
kommentaren gelesen der kef hat mir
eigentlich glaube ich die tribal rüstung
empfohlen viele von euch haben gesagt
mache lieber die scale rüstung ich hab
allerdings von der post schon in hellen
gemacht das heißt ich laufe dann hat
einfach nicht so optimal ist doch mit
die lässt oder ja ja ich glaube schon
also die trial ist so ein mischmasch
stehen das eigentlich nicht so viel
bringt aber es ist so totenkopf ist
überhaupt sehr schade ich weiß es nicht
wenn man in elm an wenn man vielleicht
doch die scale ich habe genügend mexiko
lässt es vielleicht noch da
ich brauche jeder junge ich brauche
nicht noch sehen wo kriegt mit leder her
was machen denn die ganze schweine wir
sind einfach was von broken fans alter
habe das sogar erlaubt dass ich von dem
was neben darf all die mir alles geklaut
haben oh du scheiß blauer schleier du
dreckiges du was kriegt eigentlich nicht
unerlaubt sachen nehmen aber mehr ist es
erlaubt dass nokia das noch mal
ausführlich dazu und da auch mir ist das
erlaubt ok danke schön
die haben auch ein system hier inhalte
ich habe nicht mit so unorganisiert ich
bin wirklich hab jetzt angefangen mein
haus irgendwie zu bauen
und jetzt bin ich wieder in der wildnis
drin und das weiß ich was und so weiter
und so fort dann halt einfach in die
stadt ja ich bin auf dem weg aber weißt
du was das hierfür den weg ist es ist
eine reise nach jerusalem
da triffst du drei mal jesus und das 5 1
bisher ist bevor du wieder angekommen
ist einfach kein leder ich gucke da
irgendwie doch irgendwer leder hat hier
weil kühe werden ja auch kaum welche
sein oder
wir müssen wir müssen uns um sehr viel
kümmern mein lieber um ganz viele tolle
sachen
ich weiß nicht wo du bist aber wir
bewegen uns bestimmt noch eine minute
von der folge sehen uns noch das dass
das versprechen dass das gut ist eine
frauen wieder wollen
ich laufe jetzt in den sonnenuntergang
rein
übrigens sollte es läuft viel viel
flüssiger ich hoffe mal realisiert das
war jetzt habt ihr weniges gelohnt dass
ihr eine woche kein video grafik serie
kostet 250 so viel wie deine mutter war
mit bussen zwischen kostenlos macht
kasse mit mir läuft in die richtige
richtung über lothar dann doch vorbei
ich gucke einfach ja ich sag ich doch
gerade die falsche richtung ich würde
mich schon die karte nicht erkundet ist
ehrlich ja oh mein gott die junge komm
bald auch ein könig darf mal verplant
sein
was soll das eigentlich die bestehende 1
nebenbei den 65 ist das ihr tod wurde
heath ledger gestorben
lena ich 43 85 und ihr sagt die richter
konnten sich aber die hälfte dann folgen
wie ihr
ich bin ich bin ich bin ich bin ich bin
ich war so eigentlich im voraus
aufgenommen weil ich nicht gedacht ich
dachte wenn der sache von einem namen
tag ach so ach so ach das kann nicht
sein dass hier nirgends zu sammeln meint
wir hier sein können also ich glaube ich
hab's doch nicht mehr jetzt wird
übrigens leute ich habe jetzt die
defense kam nach oben rechts gemacht
weil diese minimiert die findet so
unnötig hat jetzt auch einfach weg
gemacht die brauchte er nicht ich nutze
die nie ich lud die total würzig
koordinaten brauchen nutzt sich nur 11 3
so dass für den bdi und hörte papa
pinguin für mich als ich hasse pinguine
und wären froh wenn ich mich an den
beeren rechnen hätte also ich muss mich
mal so nebenbei wirklich so ein bisschen
ich kündige einmal viel produktivität an
und ich hab ja auch so einiges aber tut
mir leid wenn manche folgen du blöd
durch die gegend rennen aber ihr mögt
das ja auch nie hat sich noch niemand
beschwert aber ich will zu nehmen wir
mal anmerken bei mir ein paar leute
gesperrt ist mir noch nicht mit heck
sind beschäftigt habe oder stein
allerdings habe ich habe gesagt ich
werde ihn erst mich damit beschäftige
werden mein verdammtes haus fertig ist
das ist halt nun mal noch nicht fertig
dass das da kam ein vogel geflogen
schätzt sich nie dort auf meinen schoß
und ich dachte es wäre ein monster weil
ich hier bleiben muss aber was bringt
die blauen pilze diese leuchtenden sind
mega welt und ich glaube jetzt einfach
mal vorbei also ich glaub ich hab ich
schon ziemlich oft gesehen als bin ich
wieder da wo ich damals so richtig mies
und dreckig verreckt bin erst mal nicht
so toll das war einfach richtig scheiße
ich sollte mir vielleicht war einfach
einen wegpunkt setzen beim dorf ok ich
muss jetzt ja manche auch die richtung
laufen okay ich laufe hier da da da
wären wir damit rein gehen mit dem
simple zusammen dann wird alles geboten
ist das bei 3 mit einer schaufel land
ist ja ein richtiges killer und hell
geschaffene landet aber della casa de
los was ist mit einer vermeintlich töten
ja das gibt es gibt ja so viele bistum
here in the world ich hab 33 level ich
muss etwas verzaubern gehen das war ganz
schön jetzt einfach mal die ganzen
amadeus die ich hier sehe die können
aber du die können ganz schön durch
drehen also ich bin ich ja die können
dann schon durch drehen habe ich gehört
ja gut mal nicht im diamant rüstung
aber wir sind geil alter wie die sich
fortbewegen ja die holzkohle die gut die
rollen einfach so einmalig wie du immer
wenn du wenn du arbeitest den berg an
der stelle würde ich sagen wir entweder
diese wundervolle vorgefunden nach soja
halte ich lieber mit dem ding ich schau
halt warte ich eben da einen kleinen
einen kleinen sand block in die stadt
ist ja aber jetzt jetzt jetzt ist
schluss meint ihm in seiner liebe
freunde ich würde sagen wenn solche
verraten könnten einander lassen jedoch
in der beschreibung ich bin bei kickers
in der beschreibung wir alle lieben mich
das war die folge
mit cash und ja freut ihr euch auch das
bei mir endlich wieder läufst du dich ja
ok tschüss